[Music]  that comes from a line of jewelry so  I'll say like my grandfather was own  jewelry store owner in Indonesia and he  learned it from him and then now he  taught me when she sells you like to  know each other they asked each other  that well there you go I said H I know  it's true well  [Music]  polling a sum up Joey badass special  CeeLo green Dimas a boy body Kurt light  [Music]  okay  I'm Asian so it just don't to see an  Asian business you know succeed you know  I mean it's all about love and family at  that day so they showed a lot of love  and I'm sure I love vacuuming I like my  skunk because when I deal with him he's  humble  cheap people like a family anyone that  construction is where they might be good  at the Caroline  [Music]